[Music]
getting exciting this presidential
campaign and I'm not just saying that to
set up a joke
wait why else would you say it because
I'm really excited no everyone's
speculating now about Mitt Romney's
running mate who's he gonna pick that's
what they're wondering and the latest
rumor today is that Mitt Romney's
running mate will be a white male from
Ohio or as Romney refers to him a person
of color
that's pretty heat that's the wild side
for Oh Ohio
Vice President Biden on the attack right
now today Joe Biden said that the only
place mitt romney has created jobs is in
china now this has sparked an anger
rebuttal from romney spokesperson when
Jim bow who is from China
well I added that last yeah yeah people
might have thought that was a Ukrainian
name
or just a delightful treat to eat yeah
let's get some wynjym bowel and the
dipping sauce amazon.com founder Jeff
besos has been named the number one most
visionary person on the Internet Jeff
Bezos yeah coming in at number two the
guy who first said I'm gonna post a
picture of my junk
number two is interesting this year for
the first time ever Saudi Arabia is
going to allow women to compete in the
Summer Olympics hear the rumor is that
Saudi women are excellent runners
because they're not allowed to drive
[Applause]
this is that's just them going to the
store you know it's absurd in six states
ladies and gentlemen six states use my
thumb bagged salads sold at Walmart have
been recalled yeah these salad recall
affects approximately 100 Walmart stores
and zero walmart customers not a big
seller for them
nicely done hey speaking of food
speaking of food in July some McDonald's
workers will debut their new uniforms
inspired by the TV show Mad Men yeah
yeah also inspired by the 1960s their
wages here at 1966 level you want fries
with that
I've got exciting news for you
scientists are on the verge of inventing
a male birth control patch male birth
control guys yeah yeah here's how it
works you put on the patch and it
reminds you to tell your girlfriend to
take her birth control pill
[Music]
don't know why she came back
experts experts say there's a rising
trend of hooters style restaurants
across the United States more and more
of them and they're officially known as
breasts ron's that's true restaurants
yeah
can you believe people call them breasts
trots I prefer the more dignified term
gazonga t Ria's
let's go to Pechanga teary